he's Larry Scott the pac-12 commissioner
which I believe he's been in that office
since 2009 kind enough to join us good
morning Commissioner how are you where
do we stand with what is real and not
real as far as contingency plans of and
the reason I say this I preface is the
NFL owners were told don't talk about
hypotheticals have you know are you
telling coaches
let's not have hypotheticals with the
pac-12 and what we can think will be
football in the fall we just got out of
week of meetings with our football
coaches and one of the key things we
were discussing is scenario planning I
think it's top of mind for everyone you
know and we are we are planning a full
season planning to start on time but you
know it's so unpredictable what's gonna
happen and so we're spending a lot of
time not only within our league with our
peers and the other conferences think
about what is Plan B CD and he looked
like I mean everyone is feeling some
optimism at the moment you know plan a
for sure is start the season on time
getting the full season and that's what
we're working toward but for sure we've
discussed other other options and we'll
be ready if we need to move to those how
often do you talk to the other
commissioners well we've actually been
on the phone every morning morning for
me on the west coast since this really
started escalating back in March and we
had to shut down our basketball
tournaments we all you know jumped into
coordinating what we were gonna do is we
realized this pandemic was escalating
quickly and it could impact our
basketball tournament so we started a
process that second week in March I was
in Las Vegas at our basketball
tournament there and we were all trying
to calibrate and in period of 24 hours
it's surreal
we went from okay we're starting our
tournaments on time on Tuesday I think
we may get through this so later in the
day we connected and say we might have
to you know eliminate fans to the next
morning all deciding we're canceling
their tournaments completely that was
after we saw what happened Rudy Gobert
the night before
woke up that next morning on Wednesday
haven't spoken my presidents and
athletics directors said to my fellow
commissioners can you imagine if that
happened at a college basketball
tournament you saw one of our student
athletes kind of visible is ibly ill and
kind of escorted off off court we've got
a responsibility to shut this down right
now
since that time every single weekday
we've been on a phone call talking about
plethora of issues we've had to deal
with in terms of the shutdown now how
are we dealing with our student athletes
in a virtual world and what is coming
back look like on what pace it and in
college you know there's not one
decision maker especially when it comes
to football we all work together on the
college football playoff the season
non-conference games bolds neutral site
games so it requires an extraordinary
level of coordination if a pac-12 school
can't have students on campus can they
play football I don't believe we're
gonna play football if students can't be
brought back safely to campus I don't
think we're gonna treat student athletes
or football players as some special
class I don't think we've got the
ability to quarantine and put them in a
bubble the way some pro sports might now
what as students come back to campus
mean it might mean different things for
different schools I've been in touch
with all of our university presidents
and they're all working through their
own scenarios but it's not going to be
the new normal is not going to be the
old normal I think there's gonna be
hybrid situations in all likelihood in
terms of class size maybe it's not all
students coming back at once but I do
believe student athletes will be amongst
the earliest groups to be allowed to
come back what I was told a couple of
weeks ago by a source was that you were
gonna see football when it does come
back that the conference's are just
gonna be playing conference games and it
was probably gonna be a ten game
schedule now you might get one outlier
where the Ohio State plays Ohio
University or something that's regional
there how does that jibe with what
you've been told well I can tell you
anyone that's telling you now sitting
here in the middle of May what it's
going to be in there giving you the
inside scoop isn't a very good source
because I'm the one having the
conversations with our peer conferences
and our president
we don't know but has that been
discussed just what I told you
absolutely that's that's in it you know
if we can't play a full season and get
the full 12 weeks plus the post season
that would be a natural abbreviated
season okay move to conference only for
us that would be nine games and yes as
you know as I mention we got multiple
scenarios that's not what we're planning
on but that's always an option that
would that would be the easiest default
option right that's what you know
schools can control and frankly that's
the priority our schools like playing
each other but you know at the moment
we're planning on the full season
yeah well that once again my source is
saying that if when college football
comes back this is what he was told that
it's gonna look like you're gonna have
conferences playing conference games and
maybe one game outside also could you
see a scenario where not every school is
back not every school takes part in a
college football season yeah of course
that's possible each you know president
and Chancellor or Board of Trustees you
know will make that ultimate decision
for themselves but we've always as a
league and collectively as the five big
conferences and Beyond move together and
you know there's a that's the bias
everyone's got we want to try to get a
full season if we're gonna get a full
football season there's your three weeks
of non-conference games which requires
collective action they're Bowl games the
college football playoff is governed by
the ten conferences plus Notre Dame so
we have to work together if we're going
to get a full season and it's my
expectation that our league we've always
made joint decisions about how we shut
down I think we're going to make joint
decisions about how we ramped back up
and play and I'm wondering who tells you
you know it is it the white house that
goes down to the governor's is it the
NCAA is it Chancellor's presidents like
okay is there a pecking order here
commissioner yeah yes we all have higher
authorities that we report whether it's
at home or at work but yeah in this case
it's actually a complicated rubric of
you know how
decisions get made a myth did they
public health authorities will decide
what what it appears to me at the moment
I've been on call with the vice
president you know as he's tried to
figure out the implications for college
football with my peers with governor's
offices and all that it appears at the
moment that these decisions have really
been delegated to the states and
counties that public health officials
will have the ultimate say about return
to work scenarios and that's kind of
where we fit in it's also clear that you
know decisions will be different about
when it's okay to play versus the whole
issue of when fans you know can come to
see him I think those things are getting
a little bit conflated but you know I
think you know the NFL has felt
confident they could announce their
schedule and that they're intending to
play MLB yesterday is obviously felt
comfortable they could announce they're
gonna start in July if I understood it
right and you know I think if we get to
the point where we're announced we're
intending to start we would have a level
of comfort with the discussions we've
had directly and through our schools
with public health officials that they
feel come for we got the protocols in
place and and that's a you know also
probably not getting as much discussion
out there as it deserves I'm spending as
much time with medical experts as I am
with our coaches athletic directors and
presidents right now and one of the you
know the few advantages that College has
you know if you think about schools in
our conference UCLA Stanford Washington
we got some of the leading university
hospitals and medical schools in the
country so we've got a world-class
Medical Advisory Board working on this
with us and for us not just our sports
doctors and trainers but I've got heads
of the infectious disease departments
and some of these leading schools in the
country on an advisory board helping us
write these protocols these are the same
people that are advising the White House
that are advising governor's that are
advising other public health officials
so I feel confident that we're gonna be
you know kind of a forefront of the
health and safety protocols for our
student-athletes and and hopefully when
if we think we're ready that'll bring
some comfort to the governors and the
other public health officials that
ultimately have to give us the green
light
he's Larry Scott pac-12 commissioner
before that a pretty good tennis player
the best player you ever played against
was who Larry
John McEnroe he was I grew up in New
York and Long Island and he was a
sparring partner or I was his sparring
partner I should say that was always a
lot of fun you know in an actual match
probably Andre Agassi well probably the
best win I ever had was in a doubles
match against him he happened to have
been fifteen years old okay you throw
that in it's okay
McEnroe over yelling yeah oh yeah he was
you know his persona yeah I'm having fun
a little bit watching the last answers
you guys probably are and just and I'm
thinking back about John and Yvonne
Wendell and other guy used to hit with
and there's something about these
superstars in terms of the mindset the
mentality and we've all kind of
celebrated a Mamba mentality when I
think about tennis I think about guys
like you know John Mac erosion Connors
Lindell you know the singular focus
perfection and getting the most out of
themselves and this kind of unrelenting
desire to win and then and compete at
everything that they would do and I see
some really fascinating similarities
with these athletes that become elite in
whatever sport is yeah but you know what
you're trapped by yourself those there
is greatness and but but those people
they're like Michael Jordan is trapped
too by Michael Jordan like he can't get
out of this we can turn the channel we
can go on with our life Mike stays in
this world
McEnroe stays in that world Pete Sampras
in that world and that's something that
people forget about we can escape they
can't escape themselves well you know
genius I think in this world whether
it's in sports and other requires a type
of singular focus and you know being on
a certain end of the spectrum doesn't
always you know making the most
well-rounded we got a spruce up
your office that's not your mancave is
it it's a section of my mancave my kids
I've got three teenagers at home during
this quarantine and they've taken over
my mancave when I'm not traveling it's
now a PlayStation gaming Center so so
I'm pigeon-holed here in this little
corner of the man cave yeah we got to
spruce that up though kind of spruce it
up a little bit send me some stuff yeah
hey good luck with this we appreciate
your time thank you Larry that's Larry
Scott pac-12 commissioner